who is the best gold that's a big
question welcome to Sidetrack your
Sci-Fi TV and movie channel
[Music]
so this video is inspired by a bit of a
Twitter feed at the moment going on on
Twitter somebody asked who is your
favorite go award and everybody jumped
on so I thought I would give my two
cents but I can't just say who my
favorite gold is or the best gold is I'm
gonna have to break it down a little bit
so first of all who was the most
dangerous gold it's not really a
question is it it was Anubis now Anubis
was played by several different actors
but none better than gym in the coffee
shop played by Jim
can I get a coffee
get it yourself
don't mind if I do oh I don't know what
to say his name but he's a brilliant
actor I've loved him in everything I've
ever seen him in and his portrayal of
Jim in this episode of Stargate he
wasn't just kind of charismatic and
almost likeable but when he then turns
and Daniel realizes he's Anubis he was
damn right maniacal
you got it now
foreign
[Laughter]
terrifying and just gloriously brilliant
but the character of Anubis now Not only
was he so evil that even the system
Lords of the gold ruled thought he was
too evil I mean how crazy and psychotic
do you have to be to be shunned by the
system Lords he then tricked omadasala
into ascending him only realizing
halfway through the process what a
mistake
and the rest of the ascended beings had
to step in and push him back but they
were never quite able to this energy
being kept to sort of use hosts and hold
himself within an energy force and all
of these things to try to survive but
survive he did they actually killed him
a few times and he kept coming back he
had access to a certain amount of
ascended knowledge he had access to
Advanced Technology he was able to wipe
now the system Lords he was able to come
this close thanks to the ancient weapon
under Cara this close to wiping out all
existence in the universe now he didn't
Thanos this he was going to wipe out all
existence not half all of it
how many villains in sci-fi do you know
that have ever done that
so yeah he was evil yeah he was
brilliant and yeah he was the most
dangerous of all the gold well what is
the most interesting storyline created
for one of the gold well for me that is
Lord you now this gold however evil he
was even though he became a bit of an
ally towards the end was the oldest of
the system Lords now towards the end of
his existence he began to show signs of
basically Alzheimer's he began to become
very forgetful he began to order very
strange things and actually his
um Prime had to step in regularly to
protect him I always thought that was
just a genius storyline that it showed a
Humanity almost of the goal world and
that they were not forever that they did
have still weakness it really just added
another dimension to the gold species
that we'd never seen before and I just
generally thought it was a very very
clever way of running that storyline for
me that was one of the most interesting
things they ever did with the gold
no there was one scene involving a
particular gold that actually nearly
made me cry and you don't know me very
well but I'm not a crier but it was such
a powerful and emotive scene involving
the gold that it had to be mentioned in
this video talking about the best bits
of the gold I am talking about one of
apophis's death scenes
now when he was running from the Satan
gold then he died slowly in front of
Jack O'Neill at the SGC
his host re-emerged the serpent died and
the host regained control
he says he's been in an ending dream
he hoped to awaken from it to see his
wife and his children
it was an incredibly emotive scene when
he says he was felt like he'd been in a
dream and that he was hoping to awaken
and find himself back with his loved
ones this was not just incredibly well
acted by Peter Williams but it was just
a genuinely powerful scene and one of
the most memorable scenes from all of
Stargate I said I will speak the words
of power and do the rights
you will be returned to Egypt and buried
with honor
you will pass through the seven Gates
and see your wife and children again and
Rejoice with them forever
Peter Williams playing Apophis was
always brilliant he really was the
Mainstay of the first what three or four
seasons of Stargate and he was always
magnificent but he was not my favorite
color world
and I think a lot of you are going to
agree with who I'm going with because a
lot of people on Twitter agreed
it's got to be ball right now
a lot of the scenes I'm going to talk
about now are
basically bar interacting with O'Neill
oh
Stand Out Boys
wow buddy we're just talking about you
all good
it was just glorious
um in particular O'Neill sarcasm just
came to an absolute
he's O'Neill's just seemed to bounce off
all better than even anybody else you
know he was glorious for his sarcasm in
his humor but in some of these scenes
with ball he was even more genius
so um
no tuna
the actor that played him Cliff Simon
was one of those actors who's just very
charismatic he could be incredibly evil
he could be incredibly ego maniacal and
he could have this little glint in the
eye that just always made you think he
was about to crack a smile or that
basically he could get away with
anything I bet when he was a kid he got
away with bloody murder you just know
his Nan was like oh little Cliff he's
all right and the mom's like he flushed
my keys down and loo the little back you
know and no he's always some sweet the
Winnie I am telling you this guy got
away with murder
and he did as well however much evil he
committed we still kind of loved him and
we were still kind of sad when the last
one was Final in court and murdered
after he genetically engineered clones
of himself now your attempts at meeting
the replicators head on are only going
to result
I've got a better idea
instead of helping you
why don't we sit back and watch you get
your ass kicked
that way you'll be dead and we'll be
glad now Paul was always my favorite the
gold and you can see why his character
was brought back again and again and
again so guys get to the comments and
tell me exactly what you think who was
your favorite gold but more importantly
what were the favorite scenes or
storylines that involve the gold through
Stargate that you enjoyed the most get
in the comments and tell me exactly what
you think if you are new to Channel
please like subscribe hit that Bell
notification really helps us out and as
always if you enjoy the content hit the
join button don't forget to check the
description for links to nine Chevrons
our Stargate website ask merchandise
website and things like the Facebook
link they're all in the description as
always please stay safe I'll see you
next time
[Music]